now that the time masters are gone
history has been left unguarded
everything that has happened or will happen is subject to the exploitation of time criminals
which is why history needs new protectors
it needs legends
My name is Rex Tyler
i am a member of the Justice Society
of America
that will pass the point of worrying
about the timeline
yeah
Now Sara !
i need to talk to you about the legends
i think they are all in trouble
somebody just blew up New York
- During World War 2
i think we can all guess who
that someone is
Nazis i hate Nazis
it's not like the time masters are here
to stop it we are history's last line of
defense
relax captain we got this
I'm waiting a long time for this.
- Long time for what?
- To kill you
are you sure you know how to fly this
thing
let's find out
oh my god youtubers they are fully going
Legion of Doom vs Justice Society on
Legends of Tomorrow so I'm gonna break
the trailer down and explain what they
announced the comic con
so there are a bunch of big
announcements about legends of tomorrow
season two
in case you missed it season two is
going to be all about the Justice
Society
but the big surprise of comic-con was
the other characters that they confirm
they're going to be a part of that
Stargirl, Obsidian, Dr.Midnight,
Commander Steel and Vixen
so they are doing a shit ton of Justice
Society characters and you know even
bigger surprise in my mind was when they
announced that you know you have a big
hero team-up you have to have villains
to match that
so they are going to do the most comic
book thing possible villain team up
Legion of Doom that team is going to be
Malcolm Merlyn, Captain Cold
the Eobard Thawne reverse-flash and
Damien Dark
I know a lot of your ask ok so just
careful for spoilers from aero this
either
there were some big twist with those
characters this year so Damien Dark was
killed by Oliver at the end of Arrow
season 4
but when they said he was going to be
part of the Legion of Doom they said you
know the asterisk is that he will be
from the 94'
so even though the main focus of season
2 is going to be this big Justice
Society are going up against the Legion
of Doom
they're going to be jumping around in
time as they try to stop them
so a lot of that's going to be set up in
the first episode I think they're
supposed to be a flashback with Damien
Dark in the 94'
so that will tee up there Legion of Doom
mark we have the teaser at the end of
season 1 where Hourman shows up and
says I'm part of the Justice Society
so just feels like they're making the TV
show that you wanted it to be in season 1
there were some really good moments in
Legends season 1 but it was a little
uneven so I feel like now they've got to
the point where they can do this bigger
comic book story and maybe it has some
stuff to do with what's going on behind
the scenes like that the production of
it all the way the organized contracts
the way the DC lets them use characters
so you may have heard the really cool
news that John Barrowman, Wentworth
Miller the people who play Captain
Cold and Malcolm Merlyn signed big
contracts to be regulars on all of the
DC TV shows
it was like this big overall contract
just meaning that they're going to show
up on each of the four TV shows so you
have Super Girl you have Legends of
Tomorrow
you have Flash and Arrow so there are a
couple actors that have contracts like
that that will just be jumping around
from show to show
the newest one that they just announced
to get a deal like that is Katie Cassidy
now they didn't exactly say how Katie
Cassidy is going to cross over with all
the for TV shows
because we know that she's going to
continue to be in flashbacks and air
so when we see our on Arrow she will be a
younger version of the character who
hasn't become Black Canary yet but when she
appears on Legends of Tomorrow or like
when she was on Supergirl she might do
Birds of Prey
so they haven't explained it so just
like wide open to speculation but Katie
Cassidy is going to be jumping around
and on top of that the reverse-flash
will be a series regular on Legends of
Tomorrow meaning he's going to be in
most of the episodes but he won't be a
series regular on The Flash season 3
he's only getting here in the first
couple of episodes and then maybe again
later in the season but there's going to
be a whole bunch of reverse flash
because of this Legion of Doom are in
because of Flashpoint things that are
going on The Flash
I'm actually more excited about the
reverse-flash that I am about the other
Legion of Doom characters
what about Jay Garrick though he was a
founding member of the Justice Society
so of course it makes sense that they
would try to use them on that TV show
so John Wesley Shipp the actor really
only confirmed that he was coming back
for The Flash season 3
he said that he's spoken to the
producers about Legends of Tomorrow and
all they really said is is that they can
do a lot more with the character like
they can actually bring him on Legends
of Tomorrow but they haven't written
that story yet so they're like they were
really excited to write it so he will in
the future
they just haven't confirmed which
episode is going to appear in how it's
going to work
so tentatively just assumed that you
will see Jay Garrick Justice Society
things happening during season 2 which i
think is actually way better than having
Barry Allen crossover
that is one of the biggest questions
that you guys were asking me earlier
this year with Legends of Tomorrow
season 1 was happening when will The Flash
appear on Legends of Tomorrow so if you
were on the fence about Legends of
Tomorrow season 1 or if you quit
during the middle of the season because
you didn't like the Hawkman Hawkgirl
storyline
they are going to be none of those
Shenanigans in season 2
it will be hardcore Justice Society
versus Legion of Doom and I know a lot
of you are asking about Constantine
so Matt Ryan actually did the voice for
Constantine in the Justice League Dark
animated movie
now if you don't know anything about
that like they have the animated DC
movies like they did Justice League War
they did Throne of Atlantis
so like the latest movie to exist in
that universe that they just made
it is Justice League Dark is just like
the comic book if you read that during
the new 52
it looks more like the new 52 version of
Justice League Dark Matt Ryan's
Constantine appears in that movie
I don't know exactly when it's coming
out but it's not connected to any of the
TV shows but I think they're slowly
opening the door for him to guest star
and if he's willing to do the voice of
the character in an animated movie
yes I totally think that he's willing to
come back and do Legends of Tomorrow
I think you know the funny thing all
this is they announced so much stuff at
comic-con but you really don't get any
of that from the footage in this trailer
like you just see the same old team
so if you like the trailer itself isn't
that great like they're completely
bearing the way they are showing off any
of this awesome Justice League Legion of
Doom stuff but I think the reason for
that is because they didn't start
production to a little bit after
Flash and Arrow started select Flash and
Arrow almost on episode 3
so they had a whole bunch of footage to
show off a comic on legends of tomorrow
and Supergirl didn't start production
until only recently so they probably
haven't shot a whole lot of stuff so
that's probably why you didn't see any
Justice Society stuff in this trailer
let me know what you guys think about
the idea of Justice Society versus
Legion of Doom in season 2 I feel like
that's what the show need that is what
the show should have been in season 1
which is a real quick reminder there is
a new round of the DC giveaway that's
been going on
it's still open all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video I'm going to be
doing some more Marvel stuff next then
i'll do an Arrow season 5 trailer
video I'll just announced the winner
when i post that trailer video
so get I for Justice Society and
actually you know another big question
let me know
who do you think is going to be the most
evil member of the Legion of Doom as evil
as the reverse-flash is it is going to
be really hard for him to out evil
Malcolm Merlyn well you guys wait for me
to post that you can click here for my
break down to the Thor Ragnarok teaser
that they showed off and you can click
here for my break down to the Guardians
of the Galaxy 2 footage
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight